okay I need you to be honest with me
you're not attracted to me right it's
okay I can handle it I won't be insulted
I just need to know just be honest with
me so I don't waste my time I'm not your
type right Bobby is not that you are a
very attractive guy okay well thanks so
why are you being so weird and passive
aggressive look you're being very loud
actually you like dumb guys what yeah
you heard me I see like you like
you like throwy like meat head
idiots was that what you like Aaron yeah
you want to play with the big boys huh
oh look Aaron they're fighting you want
to be in the fight you want to be back
in the old high school locker room huh
with your hockey friends like still in
the glance and Josh right huh
yeah you like that hey yeah I can be
tough oh wow I can make
what's going on
my place is near here let's go the
home
oh
um
[Music]
okay
oh
great yeah you like that yeah you like
that yeah you like it you like that you
like that oh yeah you like that yeah
yeah you like poppers
come on
and the moment
I can feel that
you feel that way too